Eternal War
for the surface world
we know what you whisper
protectors
show them Who We Are
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my new black panther 2 wakanda forever trailer
Marvel just dropped a whole bunch of new footage
with a bunch of Easter eggs so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos the movies coming
out in November of course I'm going to be doing
a bunch of videos for it also do a movie ticket
giveaway when we get a little bit closer to it
actually coming out but this trailer is just meant
to show you way more name or what's going on with
this character as well as more of what's going on
with the wakani characters what's going on with
the New shuri Black Panther they do confirm that
it is shuri as the New Black Panther and we get
a bunch more footage with Riri Williams ironheart
with a couple different versions of her suit so I
will explain the Mark 1 version of the suit versus
The Mark II and we've actually seen the ironheart
trailer at d23 with I think the Mark III version
of the suit but just starting at the beginning
of the trailer footage they start with t'challa's
funeral they're all wearing white because a lot
of cultures internationally wear white at funerals
instead of wearing black they're holding his black
panther mask obviously they debut shirty's black
panther mask at the end of the trailer one of the
big differences you noticed in her costume is that
she has way more gold in it which I think is a
reference to killmonger's Golden Jaguar version
of the suit like she was talking to him about his
new version of the suit in the first Black Panther
movie and his whole thing is that he didn't want
to be showing like the whole idea is that we want
to stay off the radar so let's avoid the gold
highlights but shuri is all about the showy style
of it all kind of like killmonger was he also
noticed the exterior of her black panther suit
has the same tattoos that she had on her forehead
in the first Black Panther movie and obviously
this is her holding t'challa's black panther mask
and that just meant to parallel her becoming the
next Black Panther because the voiceover which
comes from namor during this funeral procession
is how broken people become the best leaders
which is also meant to be a reference to him
becoming leader of his people like he's a prince
of his people I believe his parents also died in
a similar tragedy to Black Panther's father to
Chaka so the sad music at the beginning of the
trailer is a reference to both of the characters
like shuri lost her brother t'chala but namor
also lost his parents that might have something
to do with the big conflict that's happening in
the events of the movie one of the big things from
the comics that they're doing is his wing defeat
like he is meant to be a mutant in the MCU he's
been a mutant for a long time now meaning that
mutants have existed in the MCU like I think Miss
Marvel is like 15 16 years old during the events
of her Series so like she's been around for that
long mutants have been around for way longer than
that we just haven't seen them yet we just learned
in Deadpool 3 Hugh Jackman's Wolverine is coming
back he's a core X-Men character the movie is
going to take place in the MCU per Kevin feige
and Marvel Now the entire movie might not take
place in the MCU like they might have a little
bit of Multiverse stuff going on or Deadpool will
at least joke about it but clearly they're rolling
hard on mutants through Marvel Phase 5 introducing
them or revealing why they've been hidden this
whole time and I think the idea is that they're
actually going to release that new X-Men movie
during Marvel phase six they just haven't
announced when yet but it is always possible
that gets pushed to like right after Avengers
Secret Wars I think by the time Deadpool 3
comes out then we'll know a lot more about what's
happening with the actual new X-Men namor is also
called the first mutant in the comics because he's
like the first mutant based character to debut in
comics just in general so they might have some
references about that in the movie too like in
the MCU they might call him the first mutant one
of the big changes though for his backstory is
Atlantis so in the comics he comes from Atlantis
they obviously want to avoid the comparison to the
Aquaman movies so what they're saying in the movie
is that in the MCU the city that he comes from is
called talocan it's based more on Aztec and Mayan
culture and the whole idea is that their race just
descends from ancient Aztecs and Mayans in real
life the name talocan is actually based on one of
the underworld Realms in the Aztec codices ruled
by their rain god named talock in Aztec mythology
it's meant to be this paradise for Souls who died
of water or storm-related devs in the comics that
God character is the storm God teteo in the
trailer you hear umbaku talking a lot about
Namor in the way that his people think of him he
says his people refer to him as cukulon which is
the feather serpent God that God is actually based
on real life Mayan mythology but it's why he wears
a suit with a headdress but it's a reference to
his winged feet his mutant abilities his powers
his people think of him as a God the way that
you would think of Thor as a guy like Thor is
an actual God in the MCU but namor is really just
a mutant the actual cuckoo con God in real life
Mayan mythology is this Mesoamerican serpent deity
worshiped by their people in the Yucatan Peninsula
before the Spanish Conquest so I think part of
the idea in the MCU in their people's history the
Spanish Conquest happened in some of their people
migrated to this different area of talocan and
eventually it descended beneath the waves but the
whole idea is that they'd kept it hidden and it
contains vibranium and the reason why they find it
is because of Riri Williams technology when she's
hired by a group of scientists who I think are
going to be backed by Doctor Doom like he's going
to be revealed to be the person who's pulling
the streams behind this kind of orchestrating
things from the Shadows I don't think that we're
actually going to see a version of Doctor Doom in
the movie they might just tease him at the end
like they'll tease that Von Doom is behind the
funding for Riri Williams technology that was
trying to find vibranium everybody in the MC
wants to get their hands on that sweet vibranium
and as you can see even though it's beneath the
waves and it seems like they have a very different
type of people they're meant to be highly advanced
ants like the wakandans like they are a threat
to the wakandas and all their weapons are also
made of vibranium all those Spears that you see
are made of vibranium that's why the wakanas are
so worried about them because their Shield won't
protect them otherwise they wouldn't really care
it looks like namor's people attacked this vessel
that's searching for vibranium getting close to
their City they have a bunch of scenes of umbaku
and his people up in the mountains of wakanda
all these ships just seem like supplies they're
faring around I believe he has a much upgraded
role in this movie and I think a lot of people are
theorizing they're gonna split the roles of the
Black Panther in the ruler of wakanda I believe
that shuri like they show in the trailer is
going to be the New Black Panther but I think the
umbaku is actually going to take over rulership of
wakanda because you see a whole bunch of vermanda
in the first part of the trailer but then in like
the later footage when things get real crazy you
don't see any of her so I think something probably
happens to her during the events of the movie
mbaku also seems a little more shrewd when he's
talking about Namor whereas raimonda seems like
she goes on the war path like in the previous
trailer she says she's lost her entire our family
and it makes it sound like she thinks that shuri
is dead there might just be some twist with her in
the movie before she comes back as the New Black
Panther but for a little while she might think
that her entire family is dead like both t'challa
and shuri and her husband so I think part of the
idea is that you have this Brewing conflict with
Namor and wakanda and she doesn't help anything
like she kind of makes it worse love the special
effects for name words flying too like it almost
looks as if he's jumping across the sky one of the
other brand new things that they show you in this
too is Michaela Cole's character who I believe is
playing a version of The Midnight Angel she might
be Anika's character the midnight angels are
sort of like a special Elite group of the door
milage like as hardcore as the dorm Elijah are
they're one of the most badass fighting forces
in the MCU on the planet within their Force the
midnight angels are like the special ops team they
have upgraded armor there's also footage in the
trailer that seems like her character is fighting
against the regular Dora melange so it seems like
there's some big division in their ranks and that
probably has something to do with the conflict
over Riri Williams with Namor and wakanda all
this stuff going on behind them in the lab here
is vibrate related like the ship is being invaded
by this Force probably on the orders of Doctor
Doom secretly looking for more vibranium for his
technology this is ReRe Williams with a version
of raimonda and this is Namor hovering outside the
throne room waiting to attack them with his spear
like he gets ready to throw his spear through
the window here remember it's a vibranium spear
he has vibranium so that's why he's able to do
this this is namor's people coming after Riri
Williams because it sounds like they believe that
she's responsible for Doctor Doom's people finding
their City this is their vibranium spear coming
through her car and I believe her license plate
is a reference to the first appearance of Riri
Williams in the comics which was an invincible
Iron Man number seven I think this is meant to be
shorty on the motorcycle with her and this is her
in her Mark 1 suit later in the trailer when she's
in wakanda you actually see her creating her Mark
II suit this is actually what it looks like it's
very close to the comic book version of the suit
her Arc Reactor looks kind of like a heart that's
why they call her ironheart this is just raimonda
addressing the United Nations I think this is
just the old whole idea that things are heating up
because the rest of the world wants that vibranium
this is just more of namor's people attacking them
with water flooding into wakanda that's meant to
be a bit of an Easter egg for the comics where
namor actually gained the powers of the Phoenix
during this big arc and wound up flooding wakanda
they're not doing the Phoenix during this movie
that's like way further off in the future as you
can see they're doing a little bit of the heads
up display like they did for Iron Man's character
like you'll see her inside the suit I think this
scene of shuri with the fire all around her is
meant to be her inside the ancestral plane and
I think that's how they're bringing a version of
killmonger back because he is supposed to appear
during the movie at some point and that also kind
of influences her choice in using all the gold
kind of like killmonger's suit on her black
panther suit and because in every new movie when
people get new suits they always do new things I'm
wondering what other upgrades this suit has that
makes it different from t'challa's Black Panther
suit like obviously it looks different I'm also
assuming that it has some different abilities
as well the really cool connection between
shuri becoming the Black Panther and doctor
Doom versus wakanda in the comics is that t'challa
actually passed the mantle of black panther to
shuri in the comics right after the Doomwar
storyline when Doctor Doom invaded wakanda
to try and get their vibranium so there's a
lot of references and Easter eggs for that in
this movie but like I said I'm not expecting to
see Doctor Doom actually walking around in this
film I think there'll just be some small teaser
and then they'll introduce him in some future
project and speaking of future Doctor Doom stuff
the Ironheart series will also have some Doctor
Doom references in it too because they said that
that series is going to be all about the balance
between magic versus technology and that is Doctor
Doom like he is man of magic in a man of science
as well and also because they're doing the new
Fantastic Four movie they might wind up doing a
version of King in that film instead of doing
a version of Doctor Doom as the villain look
they don't want to do the exact same thing the
previous Fantastic Four movies have done and
Doctor Doom has always been the villains of those
films so when we actually see them cast someone as
Doctor Doom and he actually shows up in a film
I think it'll be something different like it
won't be Fantastic Four if you spotted any other
Easter eggs and references in the trailer that I
didn't talk about in the video just write them
Below in the comments and if you have any big
questions about what's happening with the plot
of the movie or the characters just in general
I'll do more trailer videos as we get more footage
for the movie but everyone click here for my new
Deadpool 3 Wolverine trailer video and click
here from my new house of the Dragon episode
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!